In 2006, two years before the Marvel Cinematic
Universe turned superheroes into the biggest
thing in Hollywood, Tim Kring and future Marvel
TV guru Jeph Loeb ntroduced the world to Heroes.
A high concept science fiction series built
around a modern superhero mythology, Heroes
ran for four wildly uneven seasons before
returning in 2015 with the 13-episode epilogue
Heroes: Reborn.
So what else has the cast of Heroes been up
to since the series ended?
And how has time treated your favorite stars?
Here's a look at what the cast of Heroes looks
like today.
Milo Ventimiglia
Prior to his breakout role as Peter Petrelli
on Heroes, Milo Ventimiglia was known as the
irascible and romantic Jess on Gilmore Girls.
Through every action-packed moment on Heroes,
Ventimiglia never failed to find the aching
humanity in his character, and was often the
heart that held the series together.
These days, Ventimiglia is still providing
the heart and soul on a major TV smash hit
as Jack Pearson in the beloved NBC drama This
Is Us.
From Gilmore Girls to Heroes to This Is Us,
Ventimiglia is already a TV legend - and he's
only in his 40s!
Keep on rocking, Milo!
Hayden Panettiere
The catchphrase "Save the cheerleader, save
the world" helped turn Heroes into a hit - and
Hayden Panettiere into one of the hottest
new stars in Hollywood.
As cheerleader Claire Bennet, Panettiere was
at the center of the series right from the
show's opening moment.
Though Panettiere didn't appear in Heroes:
Reborn, she's still been plenty busy over
the past decade.
Besides having a daughter with her partner,
heavyweight champion Wladimir Klitschko, she's
also appeared in films like I Love You, Beth
Cooper and Scream 4.
But she's best known these days for her starring
role as Juliette Barnes on Nashville, which
earned her two Golden Globe nominations over
the show's six hit seasons.
Zachary Quinto
Brain-collecting psychopath Sylar was the
terror at the rotten core of Heroes, hunting
down and killing some of our favorite characters
- not to mention his own mom.
But there was a plus side, as Sylar also introduced
the world to the talents of Zachary Quinto.
Since then, Quinto has become a power behind
the scenes as well as in front of the camera,
producing films like Margin Call and TV shows
such as The Chair while helping relaunch Star
Trek for a new generation as the iconic Mister
Spock.
"Khaaaaan!"
Masi Oka
Prior to taking on the role of time traveling
salaryman Hiro Nakamura, Masi Oka was best
known for a small role on Scrubs.
But as Heroes' breakout fan favorite Hiro,
Oka rocketed to fame, earning a Golden Globe
nomination in the process.
And he hasn't slowed down, either.
Besides making a cameo in Heroes: Reborn,
Oka earned a legion of new fans thanks to
his seven year run as fan-favorite Max on
Hawaii Five-Oh.
We can't wait to see what he's going to do
next.
"Yatta!"
Greg Grunberg
Fans of J.J. Abrams' series Felicity and Alias
would be quick to tell you all about the heartfelt,
common man sincerity of actor Greg Grunberg,
who played telepathic detective Matt Parkman
on Heroes - and shockingly turned to the dark
side as a bad guy in Heroes: Reborn.
Outside of Heroes, Grunberg has been keeping
active by appearing in pretty much every project
Abrams has ever done, most notably as pilot
Snap Wexley in Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
And in 2014, he completed a multi-episode
stint on Showtime's hit series Masters of
Sex.
We're still waiting for Grunberg to get the
leading man role he deserves, but we get it
- playing J.J's personal mascot has to take
up a lot of his time.
Jack Coleman
His name is Jack Coleman, but to Heroes fans,
he'll always be the man in the horn rimmed
glasses, aka HRG, or Noah Bennet if you're
being really formal.
A morally gray agent who specializes in hunting
down people with powers, Noah's motives are
always kept close to the vest except when
his daughter Claire is involved, in which
case HRG always makes it clear that family
comes first.
Beyond Heroes, Coleman has spent the last
decade appearing in numerous guest roles on
TV shows from The Office to Castle.
We're not sure where he's going to turn up
next, but one thing is certain: you haven't
seen the last of Jack Coleman just yet.
Ali Larter
She broke into Hollywood with a bang thanks
to her now iconic whipped cream bikini scene
in Varsity Blues, and scored raves opposite
Reese Witherspoon in Legally Blonde.
But Ali Larter's career never quite took off
the way fans expected, with the notable exception
of her star turn as Niki Sanders - and Niki's
various doppelgangers and split personalities
- on Heroes.
Since Heroes went off the air, Larter has
starred in TV shows such as Legends, and has
gained a new generation of fans thanks to
the Resident Evil franchise.
Now that's the real cherry on top.
Sendhil Ramamurthy
Genetics professor Mohinder Suresh is one
of the characters that kept Heroes functioning,
narrating the action while also providing
all the pseudo-scientific exposition necessary.
"And what now?"
"We wait a few seconds and see if the enzymes
attach to the cortisol."
So what has star Sendhil Ramamurthy been up
to recently?
Besides reprising his role as Dr. Suresh in
Heroes: Reborn, Ramamurthy has also had major
roles in shows such as Covert Affairs and
Reverie.
And from the looks of it, his real super power
is apparently never aging.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!